All right, guys, I know what
I like to see in dick pics,
and it's not what
you all have provided.
I want to see you.
I want to see what you're into.
I want to see your interests.
Or I just want to see your dick.
[ Laughter ]
I'll show it to you.
I will see it later.
[ Laughter ]
Let's do it.
It's awesome.
I love that you left
your socks on.
That's a great look.
I want to showcase you as,
like, a foodie for this picture.
I want to put your dick
in a bánh mi bun.
-[ Laughs ]
-If you want mayonnaise,
you have to supply that
yourself, but, like, we'll...
We're good.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
Excuse me.
There's a hair in my sandwich.
[ Laughs ]
I want to focus on something
that a girl would be like,
"Ooh, like,
he's well read."
So let's just set your dick
on a book.
Maybe, like, let's flip
a page over
and just like,
"Ooh, peekaboo."
Can you please not make eye
contact with me?
I would feel more comfortable if
you would like, maybe stare at
the ground or something.
>> OK.
Like, now, could you maybe do
that.
So, I found this, like,
adoptable puppies flyer.
Perfect.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
Oh, my God.
They're so cute.
-Do you play guitar?
-Call me Hendrix.
Do we have anything
smaller?
We have a ukulele.
-Thank you.
I think this would be better
for everyone.
Yes.
[ Laughter and applause]
There once was a blonde girl
named Nikki
Stop it. Nope.
Done.
Every, like,
fat Hawaiian man just died.
[ Chuckles ]
All right, guys, what we've done
so far has been great.
We made your dicks beautiful.
Now let's make them
unforgettable.
Okay, Jay, we want to give you,
like, a look
where it's like you're going
back to school.
It's leaning against
this locker.
Okay. We need your dick
to kind of, like,
maybe stand up
a little bit.
Is there any way
you can reach around?
Oh, no.
Looks like I'm gonna
have to do this myself.
I'm a doctor, I'm a doctor,
I'm a doctor.
[ Laughter ]
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
Oh, my gosh.
This is amazing.
He puts the "cum"
in "homecoming."
So, your dick is just,
like, relaxing.
Have you ever had tweezers
next to your dick?
[ Camera shutter clicking ]
Have you ever been --
[ Laughing ]
Please just be professional,
okay?
I'm putting little, tiny
cucumbers on your penis.
Really love this.
Okay, I am super excited
about this one.
We are gonna take your dick
to Paris.
[ Camera shutter clicking ]
Oui, oui.
I wish your dick could have
a cigarette, but, you know,
we don't want to influence
the kids
that you might be
sending this to.
[ Laughter ]
A tisket, a tasket.
Your dick's carrying
a basket.
[ Chuckles ]
I Louvre this.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
Congrats, you guys.
Send the picture.
One, two, three.
Send!
[ Cellphone chimes ]
Oh, shit.
[ Laughs ]
What'd she say, what'd she say,
what'd she say?
She said,
"Worst paper cut ever."
Yes! Yes!
[ Cellphone chimes ]
I got a response, too.
"Can't wait to get my
recommended daily serving
of dick and cilantro."
[ Laughs ]
That's a success.
Look at you.
You're glowing.
This was not the face
of a guy
who had just sent
a normal, old dick pic.
And for all you guys
who didn't get responses,
it's probably 'cause they're
just masturbating feverishly.
So, we did it. Yes!
[ Camera shutter clicks ]